[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to my
36th episode of chess trap well in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful trap in the frits variation
from the black respecting the opening
arises after the following model evil
'if i Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop
to c4 Knight to f6 and now white plays
this aggressive setup starting with
Knight to g5 attacking on a weak epsilon
spot okay
black response is almost forced he has
to play d5 and after he kept his defy
the most popular choice here is Knight
to e5 which leads to a big theoretical
line however I am going to propose here
a very tricky
Fritz variation which start with Knight
to d4 and this move already sets up a
cunning trap now before we move on the
important point I like to mention that
if you open and continue at this point
with the move c3 then you should respond
with B Phi and you can check out the
data base as well as theory section
which will give you a very good idea how
to play against the mainline however if
you are playing against a practical
player or your students are playing
district or state level tournaments such
as under 700 912 then this trap is worth
to show them as many many players has
made this blunder namely d6 which is so
natural white is renewing the threat on
f7 and now it seems like it is very
difficult to defend on f7 funny enough
in the
a bass there are more than 300 games
played from this position and the
highest elo trap is a grandmaster rated
2500 so isn't that amazing
anyways let's see what is wrong with
this beautiful move as black plays the
equally cunning move Queen captures d6
telling white do your vast on f7 there
are two ways white can capture on f7 but
let's look at the first worst option
which is again most of only played
namely Knight captures f7 attacking two
big guys and what can be the more
neutral than this well believe it or not
white is completely busted
after this more yup you heard it right
as black has this wonderful resource
Queen to c6 attacking the bishop as well
as the G to pawn and now suddenly white
is feeling the heat from this position
okay White has few options but first of
all let's look at the worst one as if he
opened become greedy and captured the
rook on the h8 then this is the last
time he's going to do it and after Queen
captures g2 attacking the rook rook to
have fun and now can you see the winning
mo yup and it's Bishop to g4 and white
can pack his bag and go home the only
response is f3
but after Bishop captures f3 rook
captures f3 and the Moon Knight captures
f3 check white King doesn't have any
hiding square so why it has to give up
the Queen and even after this you can
easily see what has to minor piece
against the Queen and upon which is
never going to be enough in a practical
game
well the second option who I can try
over here is to defend this mission
either with D 3 B 3 or even night
captures Aoife which is somewhat more
critical but even after this black
Mordor doesn't change as he's going to
take on g2 and after rook to have fun
yes this time around our Bishop cannot
come to g4 but White has other problem
to solve namely Quinn to e4 check ok
white responses force he has to block
with the bishop but now you will see the
cute point behind this check has again
we are going to nab the White Queen with
this deciding blow
yup you already see it right
BAM so again and again in this line
black is winning the White Queen in an
outright fashion so finally if Queen
captures g2 is that much harassing why
not castle on the Kings side and defuse
all black threats so White's idea is
very simple if you take the bishop then
he will take the rook in the corner and
white can have a good middle game but
guess what still this is not enough as
after Queen captures Bishop Knight
captures rook yes for a time being
White is an exchange AAB but see
yourself as night capture C to ruin all
coves as White is also losing the rook
in the corner well why can wriggle with
some moves like d3 Queen to c6 and now
Knight to c3
but after Knight captures a1 we have a
unique scenario where both the Knights
are sitting in the corner but not so
surprisingly
black emerge with extra piece and a
better position okay so if you open in
place Knight captures f7
is on the ball so some Vice player come
up with this Bishop check which
obviously misplaced the black King but
surprisingly enough again in this line
it is only white who is having huge
problems first of all here black has the
obvious threat namely at six and the two
of white piece is hanging and white
Bishop cannot go to sea fool as Queen to
c6 leads to the same
trapa territory so white response is
force white has to play Bishop to b3 so
if allowed then Knight to f7 is now
definitely on the card but this is what
I like about this radiation from now
onwards every move is forcing and the
sequence start with nightcaps b3 a
captures b3 obviously Weist want to open
up the rukon the e-file
now you play at six kicking this Knight
back to f3 followed by e fo attacking
this night one more time
if Queen - E - then king - we have seven
and what has to move the knight anyways
so accordingly the base response here is
Knight goes back to his original square
namely Jeevan and now you can continue
it came to f7 as I highlighted over here
black has a very effective plan of
campaign namely Queen to e5 followed by
Bishop to d6 rook to e8 and if it's
required then King can do the artificial
castle with King to g8 and you will be
very surprised that this setup is so
effective against any white response
now to understand the potential of this
simple plan I like to show you one of my
quickest win against a 2300 rated
opponent where at this position he
continued with Knight to c3 as I have
shown I continue with Quint refi he
responded with Knight to e2 and indeed
Bishop to d6 comes into the picture
immediately which stop right to castle
okay my opponent responded with d4
I capture with and % and he captured
back with the Queen now comes the third
step yup you already know it rook to e8
pressurizing the e2 night and
accordingly
my opponent quickly find out that
castling on the King side is never going
to be possibility so he played Bishop to
d2 in order to castle on the Queen side
but you can see what setup is so passive
and with the two bishop pair I get the
charge immediately with Bishop to a5
attacking the Queen Queen to c4 check
and now simple move King to f8 after the
as expected castle on the Queen side now
comes the move which you have to
remember and this is such a wonderful
move which gives black a completely
upper hand in the game are you ready b5
so obviously white can take on B fire as
the end of the sequence e to Knight
Hanks and what this mu does is it
clearly get the initiative on the Queen
side which is very hard to defend see
yourself how quickly my opponent perish
in the game white played Queen to f4
trying to exchange Queen but first
before comes so why can't exchange the
Queen and he has to address the night
okay he played Knight to e4 and his idea
is very obvious if I take his Knight now
then he will take my bishop and again
resulting position is somewhat better
for white but to his horror at this
point I gave him this rude shock and
this kind of tactical possibilities are
always exist in this line Black has this
deciding glow Bishop captures c2 BAM
well the idea is very obvious when white
capture this piece we come in with Queen
captures e to not only regaining the
piece but attacking the Queen and not to
forget it is now white whose King looks
bit shaky
well wisely enough my opponent continued
with Queen to f3
but after Queen takes pawn takes and the
moonroof to e2 the dust is clear and one
can easily see not only black has
regained his all material but that two
sets of double pawn
gives wide a great headache in the
endgame practically speaking this is a
completely losing position for the white
camera that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and learn this wonderful trap in the
frits variation
remember when you open and play the move
d6 allow him to capture on f7 with Queen
captures d6 and no matter how we were
white captured on f7 the full point is
awaiting for you on the board thank you
for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment and I will
meet you in my next episode very soon
bye and take care